là c'est un cas qui claquent et bing
peur que minier là après produit
beaucoup beaucoup de fruits une centaine
par an et la voyez là il ya plein de
fleurs
la console est qu'on va on voit plein de
boutons la voyez cet arbre c'est l'un
des premiers planté par hank de faux il
y à 25 ans au retour de la belle saison
son jardin se réveille les bourgeons
commencent à pointer les fleurs éclosent
et les abeilles et libellules reviennent
chaque jour c'est un enchantement pour
cette habitante de guyancourt c'est la
verdure safsaf échanger des idées qu'on
arrive dans le jardin bon on oublie tôt
au jardin dont vient pour s'amener pour
reste deux trois heures on voit pas le
temps passer
même sous la pluie on y va on reste on
ne sait plus décoller dès la bananier
nénuphars ou légumes une centaine de
variétés de plantes différentes
cohabitent ici et lui permettent de se
nourrir mais son amour pour ses protégés
l' empêche parfois de les cueillir la
regarder la belle salade
normalement il fallait y aller les
manger elles sont presque trop haut trop
grosse déjà mais ça me fait de la peine
début que je ne veux pas trop couper
cette passion du jardinage
hong a souhaité la transmettre au plus
grand nombre d'abord membre des
jardiniers de france pendant une
quinzaine d'années elle a créé sa propre
association jardin passion partage il ya
cinq ans en fait souvent la bêtise les
jardins
quand je vais voir quelqu'un
qui est un jardin même petit mais bien
organisé bien bien présente et j'ai
demandé d'ouvrir son jardin et c'est
comme ça que c'est convivial et les gens
sont d'accord voilà on fait les visites
surtout c'est le partage l'échangé le
partage surtout surtout cela on cherche
à échanger entre nous à se donner des
idées à s'entraîner aussi aujourd'hui
130 adhérents font partie de
l'association sensible à l'écologie à la
protection de l'environnement en
organisent et participent aussi des
animations lors de la semaine du
développement durable de
voisins-le-bretonneux atelier cuisine
son autre passion
il nous donne un panier avec les légumes
dedans de l'aprécial au de débrouiller
pour faire des plats une entrée un plat
un dessert ses lacets de la desjardins
sélassié ses légumes pour la somme et
qu'on a planté qu'on a ajouté vu que
quand sa grande et mais après bon ben on
va on va transformer ces légumes la 1ère
place des moments de partage pour
retrouver des amis comme elisabeth
qu'elle connaît depuis 9 ans j'ai
rencontré plus d'une fois dans la
cuisine d'ailleurs que la pratiquement
on a fait des ateliers ensemble et puis
ça marche bien on tire on ramène du
monde et puis voir la cuisine très bien
elle est très sympathique en plus les
curieux pourront aller visiter son petit
havre de paix nous samedi de juin avec
le musée de la ville une découverte
historique et botanique